There are even more problems with simply sorting objects and drawing them
roughly back to front. For example, notice that the back faces are not shown for
any transparent objects. If you turn back faces on, you'll start to get strange
rendering art effects. Some back faces will be drawn before front faces blend
with them, some won't, giving this patchy look. For example, here's a view of a
block from the side, along with an order that the phases are drawn. Since phase
1 is drawn first, phase 2 blends with it. Phase 3 is drawn filling the z-buffer
and also blends with phase 1. Phase 4 is behind phase 3, so is invisible when
rendered. Of the two back faces, in this case only phase 1 has had an effect on
the image generated. Even with back face calling on, and a good sort order, you
can still have problems with different sized objects. Say a ground plane and a
red object resting in it are both transparent. The middle of the ground plane is
closer to the camera. So by sort order, it will be drawn after the red object.
This will make the ground plane appear to be above the red object. Here's one
more problem with transparency. Complex objects can have two or more surfaces
overlapping a single pixel. Again it depends on draw order as to what appears on
the screen. If the fragment on the left is drawn first, then the fragment on the
right will en-properly blend with it at this pixel. There's even research about
the ordering of triangles in the mesh itself to avoid these problems. But this
type of technique can be costly to apply. At this point you might have given up
all hope for transparency always working right. The z-buffer was meant to store
only one object at a time and unless you can guarantee the order of objects
covering the pixels, there's little else you can do. There are some further
tricks you can do by only reading and not writing to the z-buffer, but there's
no perfect solution. If you desperately want to get the right answer, there is
one technique that works fairly well called Depth-Peeling. The idea is to peel
away each transparent layer until all layers are processed, by storing an
additional minimum z-depth for each pixel. So for example, the first layer is
all the transparent surfaces closes to the camera. The second layer is all the
second closes surfaces. The third and fourth layers are processed and turned
until the whole object is rendered. That's conceptually the key idea, see the
additional course materials for more about this algorithm. The draw back is that
each peel operation needs to have all the transparent objects rendered again.
Many passes may be needed before all the layers are found and processed.
Ultimately what would solve the transparency problem is storing a list of all
the transparent fragments in each pixel, along with their depths. This approach
is known as the A-Buffer. Once we have all this information, we can then combine
these fragments in the right order. This type of storage is possible in newer
GPU's for the desktop, but can use a considerable amount of memory. What's
interesting is that mobile devices usually use a different architecture called
Tile Based that can more easily keep such fragment lists around. Yet another
approach is called Stochastic Transparency. Which uses Screen-Door Transparency
width in the pixel itself, along with some randomness to get it a reasonable
average result. This brings us full circle back to the original transparency
algorithm I presented. There's no simple answer on the GPU.